I feel I feel happy because being a
father gives me the opportunity to recalibrate
my priorities a smile a hug
air to the water and such simple words
can mean to our sons and
daughters they are always watching what we
do what we don't do what we say
what  that we do not say how we treat
each other as we speak we are the example and
they are going to treat their family they are going to
learn the good and the bad it becomes
difficult when when you are a father because
you do not know how there is a manual that tells you
how to be a father or  how to react to
different things types of ages in which
at a certain time you are a teacher at
another you are an active person who
has to be a guide at another you have
to be a friend so
they don't teach you or don't believe it and don't
comes into this world and the father, and how I
do it, does not try to set an
example, that is, how am I going to
follow my daughter to be a worker if I
am not, or how am I going to teach my daughter
to read a  lib  ro if I don't read it how are they
going to make my daughter do sports if
I don't do sports then I think
you have to create by example Natalia Lanzelotti reported
for them nothing in Spanish